body Henry died of SUDEP sudden
unexpected death and epilepsy I'm
curious how many of you have heard of
SUDEP this is a very well-educated
audience and I see only a few hands
SUDEP is when a otherwise healthy person
with epilepsy dies and they can't
attribute it to anything they can find
in an autopsy there is a suit up every
seven to nine minutes that's on average
two per TEDTalk now a normal brain has
electrical activity you could see some
of the electrical waves coming out of
this picture of a brain here and these
should look like typical electrical
activity that an EEG could read on the
surface when you have a seizure
it's a bit of unusual electrical
activity and it can be focal it can take
place in just a small part of your brain
when that happens you might have a
strange sensation one could be happening
several could be happening here in the
audience right now and the person next
you might not even know however if you
have a seizure where that little brush
fire spreads like a forest fire over
the brain then it generalizes and that
generalized seizure takes your
consciousness away and causes you to
convulse there are more students in the
United States
every year then sudden infant death
syndrome now how many of you've heard of
sudden infant death syndrome all right
pretty much every hand goes up so what's
going on here why is this so much more
common and yet people haven't heard of
it and what can you do to prevent it
well there are two things scientifically
shown that prevent or reduce the risk of
SUDEP the first is follow your doctor's
instructions take your medications 2/3
of people who have epilepsy get it under
control
with their medications the second thing
that reduces the risk of Sudha is
companionship it's having somebody there
at the time that you have a seizure now
suit up even though most of you've never
heard of it is actually the number two
cause of years of potential life lost of
all neurological disorders the vertical
axis is the number of deaths times the
remaining lifespan so higher is much
worse impact suit-up however unlike
these others is something that people
right here could do something to push
that down now what is what is Roz picard
as an AI researcher doing here telling
you about pseudo right I'm not a
neurologist when I was working at the
Media Lab on measurement of emotion
trying to make our machines more
intelligent about our emotions we
started doing a lot of work measuring
stress we built lots of sensors that
measured it in lots of different ways
but one of them in particular grew out
of some of this very old work with
measuring sweaty palms with an
electrical signal this is a signal skin
conductance that's known to go up when
you get nervous but it turns out it also
goes up with a lot of other interesting
conditions but measuring it with wires
on your hand is really inconvenient so
we in
a bunch of other ways of doing this at
the MIT Media Lab and with these
wearables we started to collect the
first ever clinical quality data 24/7
here's a picture of what that looked
like the first time that an MIT student
collected skin conductance on the wrist
24/7 let's zoom in a little bit here
what you see is 24 hours from left to
right and here's two days of data and
first what surprised us was the sleep
was the biggest peak of the day now that
sounds broken right how I mean you're
calm when you're asleep so what's going
on here
well it turns out that our physiology
during sleep is very different than our
physiology during wake and while there's
still a bit of a mystery why these Peaks
are usually the biggest of the day
during sleep
we now believe they're related to memory
consolidation and memory formation
during sleep we also saw things that
were exactly what we expected when an
MIT student is working hard in the lab
or on homeworks there it's not only
emotional stress but there's cognitive
load and it turns out that cognitive
load cognitive effort mental engagement
excitement about learning something
those things also make the signal go up
unfortunately to the embarrassment of we
MIT professors the low point everyday
classroom activity now I am just showing
you one person's day two here but this
unfortunately is true in general this
sweatband has inside it a home built
skin conductance sensor and one day one
of our undergrads knocked on my door
right at the end of the December
semester and he said Russ supercard can
I please borrow one of your wristband
sensors my little brother has autism
he can't talk and I want to see what's
stressing him out and I said sure in
fact don't just take one take two
because they broke easily back then so
he took them home he put them on his
little brother now I was back in MIT
looking at the data on my laptop
and the first day I thought I thought he
put them on both wrists instead of
waiting for one to break okay fine don't
follow my instructions I'm glad he
didn't second day chill look like
classroom activity few more days ahead
the next day one wrist signal was flat
and the other had the biggest peak I've
ever seen and I saw what's going on we
stressed people out at MIT every way
imaginable I've never seen a peak this
big and it was only on one side how can
you be stressed on one side your body
not the other so I thought one or both
sensors must be broken
now I'm an electro engineer by training
so I started a whole bunch of stuff to
try to debug this and long story short I
could not reproduce this so I resorted
to old-fashioned debugging I called the
student at home on vacation hi how's
your little brother how's your Christmas
hey do you have any idea what happened
to him and I gave this particular date
and time in the data and he said I don't
know I'll check the diary diary MIT
student keeps a diary so I waited and he
came back he had the exact date and time
and he says that was right before he had
a grand mal seizure now at the time I
didn't know anything about epilepsy and
did a bunch of research realized that
another student's dad is chief of
Neurosurgery at Children's Hospital
Boston
screwed up my courage and called dr. Joe
Madsen hi dr. Madsen my name is Rosalind
Picard is it possible somebody could
have a huge sympathetic nervous system
surge that's what drives the skin
conductance twenty minutes before a
seizure and he says probably not he says
it's interesting we've had people whose
hair stands on end on one arm 20 minutes
before a seizure
I'm like on one arm I didn't want to
tell him that initially because I
thought he'd this was too ridiculous he
explained how this
happen in the brain and he got
interested showed him the data we made a
whole bunch more devices got them safety
certified 90 families were being
enrolled in a study all with children
who were going to be monitored 24/7 with
gold standard EEG on their scalp for
reading the brain activity video to
watch the behavior electrocardiogram ECG
and now EDA electrodermal activity to
see if there was something and this
periphery that we could easily pick up
related to a seizure we found in 100% of
the first batch of grand mal seizures
these whopper of responses in the skin
conductance the blue in the middle the
boys sleep is usually the biggest peak
of the day these three seizures you see
here are popping out of the forest like
redwood trees furthermore when you
couple the skin conductance at the top
with the movement from the wrist and you
get lots of data and train machine
learning and AI on it you can build an
automated AI that detects these patterns
much better than just a shake detector
can do so we realized that we needed to
get this out and with the PhD work of
Ming zur Po and later great improvements
by an Pataca this has made progress and
the seizure detection is much more
accurate but we also learned some other
things about sudha during this one thing
we learned is that SUDEP is while it's
rare after a generalized tonic-clonic
seizure that's when it's most likely to
happen after that type and when it
happens it doesn't happen during the
seizure and it doesn't usually happen in
immediately afterwards but immediately
afterwards when the person just seems
very still in quiet
they may go into another phase where the
breathing stops and then after the
breathing stops later the heart stops so
there's some time to get somebody there
we also learned that there is a region
deep in the brain called the amygdala
which we had been studying in our
emotion research a lot we have two
amygdalas
and if you stimulate the right one you
get a big right skin conductance
response now you have two
sign up right now for a craniotomy to
get this done not exactly something
we're gonna volunteer to do but it
causes a big right skin conductance
response stimulating the left one big
left skin conductance response on the
palm and furthermore when somebody
stimulates your amygdala while you're
sitting there and you might just be
working you don't show any signs of
distress but you stop breathing and you
don't start again until somebody
stimulates you hey Roz are you there and
you open your mouth to talk as you take
that breath to speak you start breathing
again so we had started with work on
stress which had enabled us to build
lots of sensors that were gathering high
quality enough data that we could leave
the lab and start to get this in the
wild accidentally found whopper of a
response with a seizure neurological
activation that can cause a much bigger
response than traditional stressors lots
of partnership with hospitals and
epilepsy Monitoring Unit especially
children's hospital boston and the
brigham and machine learning in AI on
top of this to take and collect lots
more data in service of trying to
understand these events and if we could
prevent suit up this is now
commercialized by impecca startup that
I've had the privilege to co-found and
the team there has done an amazing job
improving the technology to make a very
beautiful sensor that not only tells
time and does steps and sleep and all
that good stuff but this is running
real-time AI and machine learning to
detect generalized tonic-clonic seizures
and send an alert for help if I were to
have a seizure and lose consciousness
this just got fda-approved as the first
SmartWatch to get approved in Neurology
[Music]
now the next slide is what made my skin
conductance got one morning I'm checking
my email and I see a story from a mom
who said she was in the shower and her
phone was on the counter by the shower
and it said her daughter might need her
help
so she interrupts her shower and goes
running to her daughter's bedroom and
she finds her daughter face down in bed
blue and not breathing she flips her
over human stimulation and her daughter
takes a breath and another breath and
her daughter turns pink and is fine I
think I turned white this email my first
response is oh no it's not perfect the
Bluetooth could break the battery could
die all these things could go wrong
don't rely on this and she said it's
okay I know no technology is perfect
none of us can always be there all the
time but this this device plus AI
enabled me to get there in time to save
my daughter's life now I've been
mentioning children but sue Depp Peaks
actually among people in their 20s 30s
and 40s and the next line I'm going to
put up is probably gonna make some
people uncomfortable but it's less
uncomfortable then we'll all be if this
list is extended to somebody you know
could this happen to somebody you know
and the reason I bring up this
uncomfortable question is because one in
26 of you will have epilepsy at some
point and from what I've been learning
people with epilepsy often don't tell
their friends and their neighbors that
they haven't so if you're willing to let
them use an AI or whatever to summon you
in a moment of possible need if you
would let them know that you could make
a difference in their life why do all
this hard work to build a eyes a couple
of reasons here one is Natasha the girl
who lived and her family wanted me to
tell you her name
another is her family and the wonderful
people out there who want to be there to
support people who have conditions that
they
felt uncomfortable in the past
mentioning to others and the other
reason is all of you because we have the
opportunity to shape the future of AI we
can actually change it because we are
the ones building it so let's build AI
that makes everybody's lives better
thank you
[Applause]